[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm bringing the
fate of Saturday huncle gained in the
final season supportive leagues teasers
trailer and a few theories and
predictions of money the hunt will
finally reunite with the Starks sister
audience sense of Stark in the season 8
premiere in episode 3 he'll fight
alongside Arya John another sin epic
battle for Winterfell against the night
king and his army the hungry later in
episode 4 or 5 shall retire to King's
Landing to help her kill the Queen the
quest homage he'll fight his brother
Gregor the mountain Clegane the handle
also by my theory vinkor gambled killing
his brother but he'll probably be
mortally wounding in the process and are
able have to finish him with all that
being said let's just jump in it
starting at a quick recap about the
Hound Center cocaine or the Hound is the
younger brother of the mountain and was
the personal bodyguard of Prince Joffrey
Baratheon when Joffrey ascended yarn
throne as King Joffrey's first Center
was named into his Kingsguard despite
that being a knight himself but his
earth-days from his post at the Battle
of Blackwater after travelling is a
fugitive Victoria Stark and having close
brush with death he reluctantly travels
to the Brotherhood without banners in
hope of having a greater purpose upon
the discovery of the return of the White
Walkers and the army of the Dead the
hell now fights alongside the armies of
Jerusalem and any Targaryen in order to
prevent another long night thanks to the
season a trail RINO for a fact that the
Hound will be Manor fell in season 8
defending it from the night king meaning
that he'll soon reunite with his old
friends the stark sisters but this is
not coming unexpected having in mind
that Orient's and sour are in Manorville
while the Hound on the other hand is
heading towards that we just saw in the
any Targaryen we know they would
certainly reunite in the very first
episode of the final season and I cannot
wait to see that same scenario perhaps
the only two people he cares about the
current helps sense a lot back from both
of them were in King's Landing and even
offered to escort her back to safety
which sense unfortunately refused he
also held her sister Arya trying to
score her back to her family but
unfortunately the red wedding occurred
or you learned great deal from the Hound
and some even claim that she sometimes
and for him it's a to say that the count
will be more than proud to see hibari
has become such a great fighter in
season 7 he was so heartwarming to see
how pleased Center was but news Breen
afford him about more a safe and winner
fell and she's become such a great
fighter and I can only imagine how proud
he is going to be man he sees for
himself how good are you actually is the
hound and Arya will be a winner fell in
the first three episodes of the final
season and they'll fight alongside in
Episode three during the battle for
vinify against the white walkers however
winter will not fall a beneful and the
living will be forced to march or should
I say run for their lives south the
living will probably have to retreat to
either the Eyrie or maybe even to King
flaming while it's yet to be seen where
the living will choose to fight against
the dead next it's been hinted and
almost confirmed that the culinary will
go together for Kings Lane area to
finally kill Cersei in the Hound to help
Aria to do so by killing Cersei's
protector his brother the mountain are
you already warning to head to the
capital execute Cersei Lannister in very
beginning of season 7 and ouster she has
betrayed her family once more Winterfell
has fallen and her family has been
forced to leave their home once more
already we'll have to kill the Queen to
protect her family for more future
betrayals the Hound who will in the very
first episode of the final season
arrived at Manor velvet everyone else
would decide to help Aria since we the
mountain honoré are able not be able to
either kill Cersei or on the other hand
survive upon killing Cersei once they
sneak into the red keep the two would go
straight into Cersei chambers are you
wearing Jaime's or Qyburn face depends
who's that at this point would kill
Cersei and just when the mountain mood
joists or to kill Aria foreshadow
cleganebowl would take place The Hound
would fulfill his promise that he gave
to the mountain in season seven finale
it's not heavy tents for your brother
you know who's coming for you you've
always known this theory might have even
been confirmed by Maisie Williams who
plays Arya Stark William Steel's there
is fate in season eight by stating
there's this split vitória between
trying to be who she wants to be getting
back to back to that naivete and
innocence with her family and her
unfinished business
what it means is that our evil stick
with her family and fight for Winterfell
against the night king but a man fell
false and men are dealers of Circe's yet
another betrayal over her family she'll
have to say a temporary good
her family and going to finish her
infamous list Rory McCann who plays the
count hinted at a confrontation between
the hound and the mountain by saying
there will be a chance of squaring up to
his brother and facing those demons
ladies and gentlemen Clegane ball is
going down for years offensively looking
forward to a game ball along anticipated
death match between centering regular
gain the hound in the mountain the show
certainly seemed to set it up in season
7 finale when they can confront in his
much change brother at the dragon pit
center said remember me yeah you do
you're even uglier than I am now
what did they do to you doesn't matter
it's not how it ends for you brother you
know who's coming for you you've always
known anyways this long-awaited
confrontation between senator hound and
Gregor the mountain achill gain will
almost definitely go down in season
eight which is big hinted multiple times
by the actor who plays the mountain to
start he told the fan that his favorites
in the film happens in season eight the
only seen to be the mountains brutal
defeat of Oberyn Martell back in season
four must be the KU gamble additionally
bjornsen told Fox News that season 8 was
the hardest season he has ever done for
a game turns he said it was the most
difficult like physically and mentally
for me as a professional strong man the
prospect of season a testing Berenson
physically should raise an eyebrow might
mountain be part of an epic battle scene
the crest and crew have been breathless
still teasing for months or could they
finally see the long-awaited drop down
between the mountain and his little
brother the Hound it's also important to
highlight that burns on the mountain had
a stunt double for the first time in
game trances Nate just lately
Bernstein's playing to mashable debt
after seven season he is finally going
to have a stunt double for the final
season of game thrones in seasons past
Bronson did all the mountain stands
himself that comes as no surprise
because he's clearly built to handle
almost anything one would ask what was
beyond some filming in season a that he
could not do it himself
perhaps an epic fight scene clicking
ball most likely
Center is the younger brother of Sir
Gregor Clegane
nicknamed the mountain a monstrously
huge night and arguably the most feared
man in Westeros in his youth the
mountain nearly burned off half of
Sanders face because he found centre
playing with the toy dead the mountain
high discarded centre did not even steal
it he was merely playing with it and a
song he did not need the mountains
permission without warning or uttering a
word
the mounting grab center and punish him
by holding his head into burning brazier
the mountain was only forced to stop
after half a dozen servants managed to
pry me away from his brother the
incident left severe burn scars of the
right half of sinners face thus hugely
very scared long on that side to cover
them ever since Center has been deeply
afraid of fire as the mountain was
growing he was killing more and more
innocent people was raiding more and
more villages only to later be knighted
by prince rhaegar targaryen this
honorable man that the mountain is home
always liked honor only one year passed
since he was knighted by Rhaegar and
still he obeyed orders to kill the same
princess two children during Robert's
rebellion and brutally rate rakers wife
upon he killed her and ever since that
event is often referred to as Diwali in
stirs Mad Dog the head of House Clegane
feared throughout Westeros the mountain
is infamously dishonorable man and has
to die and the best way to see the
mountains death would be including bow
which seems more and more likely to
happen in the final season go game ball
image to beasts to brothers the ham that
the mountain would meet and fight to
death most certainly will not happen in
the first episodes of season 8
since the Hound is sailing north with
Jon Snow maintaining what you can expect
to see in the first episodes of the
final season of the Clegane brother says
the hunt reuniting with the stark
sisters one of which he protected more
than once back in King's Landing and the
other he learned many life lessons as
well as fighting
in my opinion Clegane ball is not
questionable it will happen at some
point of the final season probably in
the very final episode the outcome of
that battle is also very important and
at the same time very questionable at
one end we have the mountain whom Robb
Stark is scribed as a mad dog without
certain thought in his head it's one of
the best warriors that the Seven
Kingdoms currently has his feared words
impress the size and physical strength
the mountain is deaths wrong that his
weapon of choice is the great sword that
most men are not even able to sing with
two hands while he is strong enough to
build it with one hand his strength
gives him a huge advantage in comets
allowing him to defeat far more skilled
men although not as large as his older
brother sailor is a very large in the
formidable fighter in his own right
considered one of the most skilled and
dangerous men in Westeros Sara guarded
his first men in combat when he was 12
years old
given the time this was probably a
the young soldier during Robert's
rebellion in the first season we
witnessed a fight between those two
brothers and we've been waiting for the
second cool game Bowl ever since in that
fight the hand was shown to be able to
deal the mountain evenly they exchanged
a few blows until King Robert ordered a
halt to the madness the mountain is
doubtlessly stronger than the Hound
Miletus technical skill which fell in my
opinion we have the crucial points and
will eventually result with the Hound
finally killing his older brother in my
opinion the hunt will not kill the
mountain with his sword he'll finally
overcome his fear of fire and use it to
kill his brother this of course will
have the story of the game brothers come
full circle the mountain is the one who
burned hound so it would be a sort of
poetic justice to see the Hound get his
vengeance by burning his brother the
Hound will finally have his justice in
the final season the count will kill the
mountain but unfortunately he'll most
likely be mortally wounded in the
process and he will ask Arya to finish
him and this time our evil do it they're
hip guys centered the catechol gains
fate in season eight with some events
been confirmed and the other just
predictions same theory semi in
conclusion the Hound will definitely
play an important role in the great war
against both the night king and Cersei
and he will most likely travel with Arya
to King's Landing after the fall of NFL
to help her kill the Queen by killing
Queens most loyal protector his brother
the mountain
unfortunately that salsa verde counts
paths villainous Val feel free to leave
your thoughts about all of this in the
comment section down below
they like the Senators path through
season 8 and his end game or do you not
and if you think I missed something
please let me know and as always I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace